I would not be here if I thought it was
gonna like destroy my career forever so
I think sometimes the amount of bravery
people suggested takes pundits to wander
around have conversations in the current
era is amplified by a kind of desire to
make things all seem a little bit more
dangerous and polarized and make the
other side see more unreasonable than
they often before co-founding voxcom
Ezra Klein started his career in
political media working for mainstream
publications like The Washington Post
and Bloomberg News along with frequent
appearances on prime-time MSNBC in 2014
Klein and his cofounders teamed up with
Vox media a massive media enterprise
with influence in all aspects of the
culture through brands like The Verge
polygon vulture and more since then
Viacom has become a widely influential
presence with tens of millions of
website pageviews seven and a half
million subscribers on YouTube and a
collection of successful podcasts voxcom
bills itself as explanatory journalism
though as we'll discuss conservatives
tend to think of box comm as opinion
journalism of the political left no
matter what you think of Ezra's politics
there's no question he's one of the most
important voices on today's political
scene we'll discuss his new book while
we're polarized our disagreements on the
value of identity politics and the role
of government as well as the Internet
breaking controversy between steven
crowder and former voxcom explanatory
journalist carlos masa
[Music]
welcome to the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special today we have joining us Ezra
Klein Ezra is the editor-at-large and
founder of Vox first just a reminder we
will be doing some bonus questions with
Ezra the only way to get access to that
part of the conversation is to become a
subscriber so head on over to Daley
wire.com become a subscriber they'll
have access to all of the full
conversations with every one of our
awesome guests Huzur thank so much for
joining the show and welcome to the show
and welcome to the end of your career
since you're on the show so i'm
cancelled yeah you are I mean I hope
that you've enjoyed all of your
illustrious success so far honestly
would be good to get a rest so the book
why were polarized I want to get into
that first I want to ask a little bit
about voxcom the foundations of voxcom
so one of the things that that's great
in the book is you talk a little bit out
your own political point of view
obviously you're of the left you're
liberal you know you're drinking
ironically from our leftist years I'm
learning I'm drinking excitedly from the
leftist views tumblr this is my whole
reason for coming here today I've always
made a distinction between sort of
leftist and liberals the difference
being that liberals are people I
disagree with on taxes and government
intervention ISM and leftists are people
who are interested in going after my
advertisers nd platforming me and
ensuring that I unable to make a living
on the other side of the aisle and/or
utter things on the other side of the
aisle in the book you call yourself a
liberal so how do you define liberal
just to kind of get that out there so I
wouldn't cut leftist in the world that
way by the way number one so liberals I
think tricky to define and Purdue
because it's become under attack so now
there's a distinction between neoliberal
and leftist you have a moderately in the
Democratic primary out more left lane I
think of liberalism is fundamentally
about a mixture of equality with a
relative high level of confidence in the
ability of the government to provide
those services so in different eras in
American politics we've cut that pretty
differently so you have periods in time
where the Liberals we're somewhat open
to the state and then also periods of
time where they have been more critical
of the state but they have always wanted
to make society in general more equal
they have always believed at a pretty
firm level that people's life chances
are very defined by luck very defined by
chance and so the question of what our
just desserts are is actually a pretty
hard one to answer and once you believe
in that fundamental change of what do we
really deserve and how hard that is to
attribute then it becomes very different
what you should make sure people have to
have a fair shot in life so I
come back to in just one second I want
to ask a quick follow-up just about Vox
your publication so obviously Vox is is
sort of build this explanatory
journalism people on the right perceive
it to be left our our publication daily
wires obviously conservative we say
openly it's conservative so does Vox
acknowledged that it is a publication of
liberalism that is it is a left-wing
public I don't think you could read box
and not recognize that where we tend to
come down and most issues is
left-of-center I don't define us as a
liberal publication I never have because
that isn't a way that I want to box us
in I've tried a number of times to hire
conservatives at Vox I think I've done
that five or six times occasionally
succeeded but in general it's been
harder sometimes to open it up then I've
always wanted to look Vox reflects me
and it reflects other cofounders of the
organisation and as you know it I'm a
liberal so that's made sometimes pulling
it out harder but I don't want to be in
a position where Vox has to follow
movement wherever it goes that right now
in American politics I'm pretty
comfortable where the liberals fall in
five years in ten years I may not be and
so I don't want Vox in a position where
what it has is an identity as a liberal
publication as opposed to views it may
put it at this particular moment in
American politics on the liberal side of
things and look sometimes Vox ends up a
little bit more leftist and there are
other places where it ends up being much
more critical of sort of reigning
liberal orthodoxies like I think for
instance you look at a lot of our
housing coverage increasing I think
there's more of a connection between
EMBs and liberals but for a long time
liberals were not great I'm a lot of
occupational licensing and housing
issues at the local level we cover that
stuff a lot so it's important and I talk
a lot about identity in the book and how
it can wrap you in and box you in it's
always been important to me if there's
space for box to change and space for
the whole bunch of viewpoints which you
know three to five were able to do let
me just say the reason I'm asking the
question was not meant as a gotcha it's
more as a as a sort of recommendation
from our defensive posture with regard
to Vox because it feels like you know I
do a thing on on Twitter where if
something if a so-called journalistic
outlet like CNN which portrays itself as
objective is being overtly of the left
I'll say so much journalism and I found
myself on occasion doing that with Vox
and I feel like I don't do it with MSNBC
because MSNBC is pretty clearly of the
left they kind of build themselves of
the left and so my only recommendation
with regard to Vox is just say what you
just said write it and say it more and
more and more publicly which is of
course it sort of reflects what the
founders vision for the
site is as opposed to it's just the site
for explanatory journalism which is I
think the top line that people sort of
get I don't want to hurt things I did
not break that news here know that exact
thing many times I will say one of the
things that I think distinguishes some
of the approach we take like let me ask
you why am i drinking I have a leftist
here smug because it's funny but so when
you do that right if I wanted to sign up
as a daily wire insider the thing I get
is a leftist here smug right that is my
problem right and don't you think that
creates a very clear sense of who your
site is not for yeah well it's not for
leftist by my definition and why because
I don't believe that those people are
interested in my site existing but they
are right there are a lot of leftists
who have open minds think you define
leftist earlier in a way that I think
doesn't actually make it you know they
made this call right I mean like I know
the Reginald rabbit use liberal tears
beautify and left us a couple minutes
ago to somebody who hates you but a
lotta leftist basically what they
believe is we should have single-payer
health care things should be much more
equal and isn't it a problem to cut the
identity so sharply right to say so
clearly you guys also have that book for
Michael Knowles like what is it
reasonable Democrats there on that
there's a lot of work at the Daily wire
to say like this is our side and out to
the other side and it seems to me that
when you do that you make it harder for
yourself to move you make it harder for
yourself to absorb new information make
it harder for yourself and for your team
you can get trapped a little bit by that
audience so one of the reasons I'm a
little bit careful box is I don't want I
don't want to be trapped and too I want
people to feel it's for them if we're
not doing a good job of that if we're
not look I've no problem with where we
come down on things but it's always my
hope that people be able to see
themselves in and their arguments well
reflected right you talk a lot with my
colleague Jane Koston and one we seen
you talk about Jane Koston is that Jane
works really hard as part of the box
team to understand trends on the right
movements on the right ideas on the
right I want people on the right to be
able to read box at least feel we're
taking them seriously that we don't hate
them and you know I think the message of
leftist here's is it you don't like them
well like they're bad I do think leftism
is bad and that's why I deliberately do
slice the difference between liberals
and left us it may be distinction that
you don't agree see Democrats is gonna
include a lot of liberals they're like
what's uh that's not pickin that was
really critiquing the democratic right
and obviously a joke I mean at a certain
point you do have to say if I have to
explain the joke it's no longer a joke
but yes
we are a joky site we do have a sense of
humor about politics but I mean to your
point as far as open-mindedness about
people on the other side of the aisle as
far as I'm aware
you know we're one of the few
conservative sites where we'll have
people like you on for an hour-long
conversation or people like Jane or
people like Andrew yang or people on the
left side of the aisle and that is
something that I like engaging with and
I think it's fun I'm not going to give
up the humor of politics politics is
inherently stupid in many ways and I
think that and I think they giving up
the sense of humor for a for a sense of
sincerity that I don't think actually
reflects politics in our country is I'm
not sure that that's a winning
proposition I think also you may be more
optimistic about politics than I am
oddly I throw bouquets you know because
your your your book is very realistic
about the prospect of polarization but
sort of the way that you're articulating
the way people see your sight as opposed
to my honest recognition of the way I
think people see our sights that that
may just be a difference between in my
opinion realism and optimism on your end
our realism and pessimism I think so I
have a media chapter and I'd love to
talk with you about it because is it
something I struggle with right I
started Vox and along with my
co-founders and it's hard right I mean
you know this you built a site it's hard
and you're in a media ecosystem right
now in a media business model where it
is harder I talked about this a lot in
that chapter but things move to this
very choice-based model there's a
tremendous amount of attentional
competition the audience is more
polarized that has made the folks
appealing to the audience more polarized
right the leftist here's maguet a very
simple answer right the real answer is
that it helps you guys sell
subscriptions it's a powerful identity
right Delory you are a champion right
the the point of Ben Shapiro in some
ways in the public discourse is ben
shapiro destroys right you are a
champion for people who often feel in
colleges or in other places like they're
not being heard like nobody's arguing
for them they're getting shouted down
you come and you show no this is a fight
you can actually win and one of the
things that I struggle with in the media
is the push towards all of that as you
say the book in a way is grim and some
of what I'm trying to do in the book in
my podcast in both self-presentation and
broader rocks presentation is you're a
little bit trying to create the politics
you would like to see in the world and
the politics I would like to see in the
world is a little more open well and
this is what I found so fascinating
about the book is that it's there
so much in there that's really
interesting material about polarization
why we're polarized but I wonder if it
sort of glides the main reason why I
think we're polarized which is that
there are true and real chasm wide
ideological differences that are
breaking out in the American philosophy
right now and that all of these systemic
things that you talk about why people
polarize and why they tribal eyes and
all that can be true the question is why
now and does that reflect a broader
difference that is not merely going to
be papered over by sort of treating each
other more nicely Oh
or is it or is it so I want to get into
that in just one second first when you
use incognito mode on your computer what
kind of websites have you been visiting
have you been going over to voxcom have
you well even when you're in an
incognito mode it turns out that your
browsing history is still subject to
people taking a look at it your ISP can
see every single website you've ever
visited and of course they can sell that
information to tech giant's expressvpn
is your solution expressvpn encrypts
100% of your data with the best-in-class
encryption so your information is always
protected even when you're using public
Wi-Fi like at a cafe or a hotel
expressvpn works on everything phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares your Wi-Fi can still be protected
even if they don't have Express VPN if
you don't use the VPN and you should be
using a VPN your data gets stolen honest
like penny your fault so go get a VPN
today and protect your online activity
today with the VPN I trust you secure my
privacy visit my special link and
expressvpn comm slash Ben you can get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's expr ESS VPN comm slash
been expressed VPN comm slash been to
learn more that's expressvpn comm slash
Ben so let's talk about the book now
since we've referenced it a bunch of
times and not actually got into the
content so while we're polarized why
we'll provide whatever you buy 100% go
get it it's actually a really
interesting read obviously is somebody
who reads a lot of books on the other
side of the aisle I found this to be a
particularly informed take with regard
to especially the social science
research on tribalism and how people
group and and how people find identity I
want to start with one of one of your
premises and it's it's a premise that I
actually think it certainly divides the
two of us in our perspective on American
politics in the world you talk about
identity politics and you defend
identity politics you you have a pretty
definitive fine identity politics right
and this is why this is sort of the
question so I want I want to read you
the quote on it cuz I don't want to take
it out of context or anything so you say
unfortunately
the term identity politics has been
weaponized it is most often used by
speakers to describe politics as
practiced by members of marginalized
groups if you're black and you're
worried about police brutality that's
identity politics if you're a rural gun
owner decrying universal background
checks is tyranny or a billionaire CEO
complaining that high tax rates to you
and I success or a Christian insisting
on nativity scenes in public squares
well that's just good old-fashioned
politics with a quick sleight of hand
identity becomes something that only
marginalized groups have so here's my
question I read this and my first
reaction was this seems like a category
error to group all these things together
the reason being that in one case you
are talking about race in a mutable
characteristic of human beings that is
not innately linked to politics and in
other cases you are talking about actual
ideological groups which are innately
linked to politics I mean how you
identify as a Christian is certainly
going to have ramifications based on
your interpretation of scripture for
politics how you identify as a gun owner
obviously is going to that that is an
activity it is not you were born a gun
owner it is you chose to be a gun owner
possibly based on your feelings about
guns like for me my advocacy for the
Second Amendment began before I owned a
gun right for a lot of people who are in
favor of lower tax rates they're not
millionaires they're not building there
are 63 million Americans voted for
President Trump the vast majority of
them are not millionaires or
billionaires a lot of them wanted higher
tax rates on rich people well that
that's true ting at some at some times
Donald Trump I mean that's true but it
is also true that for the Senators who
are being voted for and for Congress
people who are being voted for that
people have voted for lower taxes in the
past I voted for lower taxes when I was
not making as much money I vote for
lower taxes now that I am making a lot
more money so the question that I have
when it comes to identity politics is
the kind of identity if you are going to
kind of lump all of this together
I do have an objection which is I think
it is fair to object to identity based
politics on the basis of immutable
characteristic because there is no
necessary conjunction between skin color
and politics whereas there is a fairly
necessary conjunction between your
religious outlook or your political
outlook and identifying with other
people who have that political or values
based outlook we tend to in life
associate with people who share our
values but if we in life only associate
with people of our same race we tend to
get very uncomfortable that I think
that's perfectly appropriate how do you
define just identity take politics out
of it for a minute what is identity I
mean in in my view I mean
identity on a broad level is obviously
all the things that make you you so
presumably
race would be a part of that of course
but in terms of what is appropriate to
bring into the political square what is
it appropriate to polarize politics
around I know I'm jumping past your
question so the argument may because I
want to make sure I'm following it is it
that race is immutable and as such it
poses and you can tell me if I'm putting
words in your mouth it poses a
particular danger to politics in a way
that something like religion something
like an ideological perspective
something like where I'm from I'm a
Californian that doesn't but the the
sense of identities chosen or built on
at least cheekier ground inherited are
different than identities that are
somehow something you can't take off yes
why is it because if the conversations
that we have about politics are designed
to shape each other if we're if we're
actually the conversations that you want
to have that I want to have the
conversations about convincing each
other if those are to have any effect in
the real world they cannot be based on
immutable characteristics because those
characteristics are immutable so it's
like Scotland they're not based on a
butyl characteristics I mean when people
once that sorry when people talk about
identity politics in coming from race or
coming from ility anything it is not
that the politics itself is an immutable
characteristic the but the argument
being made at least in part is that
something about the way you're moving
through the world whether it's because
you're african-american or Hispanic or
Jewish or Californian or you live in a
rural area is alerting you to some
experience or giving you some experience
and then at least in theory is speaking
to a broader truth I know that sometimes
when you argue this point you like to
make a cut between a politics based on
experience and a politics based on data
I think of experience as a way of
pointing you towards what is true about
the world you then have to have validate
it but nevertheless you can bring that
in the idea that you would take that out
that's something that was immutable in
you that you couldn't take off it's
something you can't have in politics
that seems wild to me I mean of course
it's something you need to be able to
have in your politics if you're having a
distinct experience because of your race
or because of your sexuality or whatever
it might be to say you're gonna wall
politics off from that not only does
that seem weird to me in terms of what
politics is for but isn't how politics
ever worked no but the the point that I
would make is that you are now
conflating experience with an immutable
characteristic and that is an argument
that I object to on the Left but I think
then what you're saying so the argument
that I'm making is if you and I share an
experience yeah right and that
experience we're both Jewish
okay but that's not an experience that's
a characteristic it is something and
moving through the world as a Jewish
person that can be similarly we will get
like a lot of anti-semitic hate on
Twitter right okay so that's an
experience right our experience advances
Medicaid but that does not suggest that
we have a common interest except against
the antis Medicaid okay when you suggest
that there is such a thing as a black
interest or as a I don't want to use
Jewish because Jewish actually has
religious and has religious overtones
obviously Judaism is both an ethnicity
and religion and you and I disagree I'm
sure very widely on the ramifications of
what it means to be Jewish even so
Jewish identity is a little fuzzy
because it actually branches off into a
couple different areas but races but all
identities are fuzzy in that way and
race is not in that not in that exactly
great all identities have big groupings
in within them and you're doing a crude
cut right whenever you're talking about
demographics are modeling the world in a
crude way that it's gonna get things
missed and wrong at the individual level
it's the problem throughout American
history and I think it largely has been
is white identitarian ISM then why is
that a problem but black identitarian
ism or Hispanic identitarian ISM is not
I think that the problem is when the
policy is bad but you don't actually
believe that and I recently the the
reason I say that you don't believe that
is because the same policy applied to
one group Noonan Owens good in a policy
that is applied to another group becomes
bad the problem is when the policy is
bad if we have a policy that it works
better when applied in one direction or
another as you se Cajun aliy do although
we should talk about examples cuz I'm
not really sure what you're referring to
there you can affirmative accurate or
example I think affirmative action is a
way of restore of writing a historical
injustice is a pretty straightforward
policy it seems to work and you're
dealing with something that has actually
happened in American history to say that
you were dealing with a very
straightforward effort there to pay down
a debt well so the the argument in favor
of affirmative action is now being based
on the experiences of people presumably
under segregation or Jim Crow and we are
now in the year 2010 first of all the
efficacy of the permit of that very much
and down according to the research of
the Thernstrom but putting in the
putting I disagree through the efficacy
is in doubt but but we don't get to go
through a brand view here but let me let
me ask you this question to straight
forward or why is it that if you are the
head of a household african-american
household and you have a job full-time
job you're gonna have a lower net wealth
on average than the head of a white
household who is unemployed or similarly
if you're head of an african-american
household you have a college degree
you're likely to have a lower net
than a white household headed by
somebody who dropped out of high school
that is speaking to something that has
happened historically right well
question to Jay right as an
intergenerational transfer of course at
some point if you want society to be
even roughly equal you're gonna have to
do something about that interracial
injustice or alternatively the idea of
equality would be that everyone is
treated equally under the law not
differentially by race or based on past
discrimination that is one accessible
quality well this is correct and this is
why when you say why we're polarized and
the implication is that we are polarized
because of tribal identity the real
reason I think that we're polarized is
because there are two very different
visions of the world and how the
government ought to operate in that
world meaning that you're you're
positing a sort of rauzein view of
justice I fundamentally disagree with
Rawls and view of Justice I do not think
that society or government is in a place
to achieve equality of outcome nor do I
think that the attempt to Thomas Knowles
phrase way to achieve to achieve cosmic
justice is something that when you say
so or desirable and achieve when you say
we can't achieve I can totally totally
buy the argument that you don't want it
to or that you think would be unfair but
I think there's a very different a very
big difference it's important to keep in
mind between cannot and should not well
I mean cannot actually you're right we
could achieve equality of outcome it
would involve the oppression of hundreds
of millions or not even equality of
outcome you can achieve low levels of
reparations for past injustice through
things like affirmative action I mean we
can disagree about whether or not
formative action works but positing that
it could just doing a little bit to try
to do things about what has happened in
the past is not going all the way
towards totalitarian let me actually
back it up for me and and polarization
because I think something in my
definition of polarization is getting
missed here all right go for it so two
things so one I agree
the polarization is dramatically about
ideology and dramatically about very
different ways of looking at the world
the argument the book is that what is
different right now is it those are
sorting so neatly by party so go back to
the 1960s let's say Civil Rights Act
right there is part of the country that
is against that part of the country that
is for it that's clearly a very big
difference in belief about how the
country should be governed what we
should do and what is right for the
government to do right I mean to take
that as more than just a racist argument
there's also a set of arguments about
you know what is the proper role of the
federal government what if states rights
etc that what is remarkable about that
moment in American polity
is it does not split by party in the
house in the Senate you have a higher
proportion of congressional Republicans
vote for the Civil Rights Act then
Democrats and then a Democratic
president of course pushed and signed it
so you have it truly bipartisan effort
on civil rights and also a truly
bipartisan opposition to it so it isn't
that we have in my view deeper
ideological differences today than we
did that I think the ideological
difference over is segregation by law a
okay or even commendable thing to have
is a much more dramatic ideological
difference in most of what we're dealing
with today the difference is that a lot
more of our distinctions drop across
party lines
not just ideological but identity as
well and it is a merging those
ideological identity experiential
demographic and then the cutting of them
by our politics it is really different
here so polarization we've always been
disagreeing and we've had much more
dangerous moments of societal fracture
than this one
what is distinct about this moment is a
degree to which they layer on to party
and then how that interacts
catalytically with our American
political institutions so I don't in any
way wipe away the idea that there's a
great evil illogical debate to have here
just that we're not in a new era of
great ideological debates but we're in a
new era of his party polarization so I
mean I agree with an enormous amount of
that and that that I think is the most
solid part of the book I think that what
I disagree with is that the prescription
is that identity politics generally
should be treated the same based on the
group that is that is claiming identity
so I want to get into that in just one
second first let's talk about your
employees let's say that you have an
employee who is so useless you
eventually give him his own show and
then you send him to CPAC where he
proceeds to be exposed to coronavirus
then he comes home doesn't self
quarantine and just comes on into the
office let's say that you wanted to
replace this terrible employee
let's call him Michael moles if you are
hiring you can try zip recruit for free
at zip recruit calm slash been guest zip
recruiter sends your jobs over 100 top
job sites with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
skills and experience for your job and
then actively invites them to apply you
can even add screening questions to your
job listing you can filter candidates
and focus on the best ones zip recruiter
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter a no
quality candidate within the very first
day so if you are looking to replace an
employee who shall remain nameless an
employee like Michael Knowles try zip
recruiter for free go to zip recruiters
comm slash been guest that is zip
recruiters comm slash
Ben gasps B and G you est zip recruiters
comm slash Ben gasps zip recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire again I
come back to the question of you suggest
that that the only question is whether a
policy is good or bad
well if good for whom bad for whom great
for them good for the majority good for
all good for good for all but in the
interests of some okay how are you
defining good because I really have
serious doubts and I don't mean to to
cast aspersions intent here but I like
to your credit I have serious doubts
that if a white majoritarian party came
up in a white identitarian party and
said the interests of white people are
the most important here also this policy
that is expressly designed to benefit
why people happens to benefit everybody
else I doubt you'd be like oh well you
know that's okay because you know that's
a sure they're white identitarian x' but
that's also helping black people so
that's okay
I think that depending on how there are
a lot of different ways to think about
whether or not policy is good or bad and
we can go through them but I think that
I want to go through identity for a
minute here because one place where I
think we disagree a little bit and one
thing that I try to define in the book
is I want people to see identity as one
obviously something we all have and
you've agreed to that earlier but also
it's a something that's challenged and
activated in politics and the primarily
the thing I'm trying to do with identity
politics here I got at MIT I'm a little
bit confused by some of the distinctions
you draw because what we're seeing in
politics all the time is that identities
converge they diverge they activate they
spin down and we need to see it as a
psychological process that spins up and
once it spins up it changes how we
relate to each other changes how we
absorb both contrary and positive
information changes how we feel about
the other party and the idea that
everybody has identity and that it all
works off a pretty similar psychological
basis in the mind I think that's pretty
much unchanged and in the social science
literature that's pretty straight
forward and so this idea that you're
gonna allow some identities into
politics and not others I don't even
know how you could do that even if you
wanted to or even what exactly you mean
like when out in the economic is that
it's more dangerous to graph politics
under certain identities than to others
and I think that's a proposition with
racial politics and religious politics
all that because you've cut those apart
from each other's religion as something
more chosen people can move in and out
of but I mean you know look well why
there's plenty of religious wars plenty
of religious violence people cleave to a
lot of different identities some of the
more racial but also racial identities
more complicated than even I think this
conversation is making them sound they
change over time right there was a time
when the Irish and the Jews were not
considered white now later on they are
but that's the earliest flexing that
nearly as flexible as simple political
affiliation based on tax rates for
example use religion as the exam so tax
rates I even use religion as an example
one of the things that the founders I
think very wisely did is they summed in
favor of separation of church and state
specifically to minimize the impact of a
state being made the weapon of a
particular religious act so the founders
recognized the the problems of religious
identity arianism right I think you're
making a figure arguing for my position
no I know the opposite you know I'm
arguing that affiliation specifically by
that there are there are gradations in
the dangers to be posed by affiliation
with particular identity groups and how
those manifest in politics and I'll
agree with you that religion is is in
some ways because it is largely
inherited from parents and because it is
not directly politically related in some
ways that in some ways it stands between
sort of the polls of race and say tax
rates but there are gradations there and
I think that to pretend that these are
all the same which is sort of what you
claimed in the book that all identity
groups to which you choose affiliation
should be treated equally in politics
and and that when politicians appeal to
those identity groups that that is not
at all well so so so explain so then
clarify for me okay because I'm a bit
confused
so clarify for me which do you think
that there are increasing or divergent
dangers based on attempts to appeal to
particular senses of identity in
American politics let me think for a
second what I think about this I don't
think it is different now than it has
ever been if anything one of the
arguments I make in the book is that
identity politics is paradoxically
weaker now as we see it more clearly so
one of the big picture arguments in
making the book is that we are in an era
of very rapid demographic change so we
are on route to being a
majority-minority nation racially by
about 20 43 we've seen the percentage of
Americans at a foreign-born go from
about 4% in nineteen seventy three or
four I think it was to about fourteen
and a half percent now that's a couple
points off from a record but we're
expected to hit a record and then bring
religion into this we are again and
route to seeing the religiously
unaffiliated become the single largest
religious group again that's expected by
demographers in about the 2040s so about
seven
ten seniors are white and Christian only
three out of 10 people under 30 are
white and Christian is a very very rapid
change in religious mores in the country
and all that is creating a lot of
pressure on the system but one of the
things that's creating is an ability for
groups that traditionally have not been
strong enough to put their needs and
their claims onto the political agenda
to do exactly that and that's why one of
the arguments I make is that identity
politics is often most powerful when we
don't see it clearly at all I mean
you've said already in this conversation
that white identitarian ism has been one
of the foundational sins in American
political life for a very long time
oftentimes it in white it's in Syrian
ism exactly it's oftentimes it is acted
almost completely invisibly like one of
the points I make in the book is it
presidential cabinets for the vast
majority of American history we're just
all white men and when that was going on
nobody said identity politics like only
white matter being chosen for this but
then if somebody comes out and says I
think we need a cabinet that looks like
America or Calvin that is 50% female or
whatever it might be that all of a
sudden is identity politics so do your
question about whether and I read that
critique right so this is what I'm
saying then I learnt not your critique I
agree I agree with the point that it is
more identity politics to suggest today
that we ought to that within today's
politics forget about 60 years ago I
agree that it was unspoken white
identitarian isms have only white males
at the at the cabinet table agreed today
if somebody says two policies one is
whoever whoever is most qualified gets
into the cabinet somebody else says I
need a transgender person on this to be
to pick my Secretary of Education as
Senator Warren recently sort of
suggested the the secondary the
secondary claim is to be significantly
more disturbing than the meritocracy
claim no matter where things come I want
to have any prep I want to hold for a
minute on first the first question then
I'll go to your second question which is
my point is simply that identity
politics has always been part of America
but it's very powerful and it was and I
don't think you're gonna get it out of
the whole thing because people interact
through not just the political system
but the world through their identity but
it's the it's one of the worst things
that has happened in American culture is
the unspoken white identitarian ISM I
agree that I agree that has terrible
dimensions and I agree that has oh maybe
I don't agree but I believe it can have
good dimensions like everything in
politics it's complicated and it can go
in multiple directions depending on
who's doing it and whether or not the
causes are going forward
sent up to some basic now
I think in the general question of how
to build cabinets that you're bringing
up there oftentimes the way people see
it is not actually that what they're
doing is betraying the meritocracy by
trying to make more diverse can cabinet
but actually forcing themselves to be
meritocratic in building something and
also creating a world where you can be
meritocratic in the future you've
created a system where it's endlessly
white privilege regenerating itself
through then it becomes very hard to
have a system twenty years from now
where there are enough people come up
through the pipeline and have had their
needs recognized and have had their
talent seen to be able to have the kind
of system that we want to have I think
one of the places that I think well the
place I'd probably disagree with you
pretty profoundly in politics has to do
with what do you do about historical
injustice now I think sometimes there's
an effort to say I called sort of zero
day equality right
as of today things are equal and so as
of today everything goes in the same
direction as of today everybody gets
treated equally and then all the
accumulated power the accumulated wealth
the accumulated position in society you
just sort of wipe it away and you hope
people are going to swim through that
entire thing it's far about up earlier
this question of an african-american
family with a head earner and a
full-time job having significantly less
wealth and a white family with an
unemployed head owner or an
african-american family with a
college-educated head earn or having lot
less wealth in a white family with a
college dropout head earner like that is
something where you see that there's
something going on in the background
there that if you simply begin running
the race right now it is not gonna be a
fair race now you have to handle these
things carefully I don't think anything
is easy right my background as you know
as a policy reporter it is hard to fix
difficult problems doesn't mean you
shouldn't try or doesn't mean you
shouldn't see them as problems well you
can you can see a historical injustice
as a problem and still recognize the
limitations of government which goes
back to one of the original statements
about kind of the nature of liberalism
optimism about the ability of government
to get this stuff done I mean Lyndon
Johnson specifically talked about kind
of moving toward a rauzein equality of
opportunity as opposed to the sort of
equality of rights that is guaranteed
under the Constitution or should be
right the the idea that equal equal
rights before law an equal application
of the law was the the basis of American
was a base of Americanism and he sort of
replaced that speaking clearly with this
idea that if that it was not a fair race
if somebody was starting off ten yards
behind which is a nice medal or girl or
hundreds of yards behind or a thousand
yards behind and that
that's that's a nice metaphor and that's
that's true - to the extent that it's
true there's only a computer well it
when I say it's true to the extent that
it's true what I mean is that there are
a couple of problems with it one
everybody in society - a more or less
extent is born different from everybody
else in society with certain advantages
in certain disadvantages and that's
accurate also everybody is born either
with a certain advantage or disadvantage
in terms of historical circumstance what
makes you believe that either it is
right and just
for the government to then come in and
act as a sort of godlike figure in
figuring out who deserves to have
something taken away from them and
handed to somebody else even if they
don't necessarily bear personal
responsibility for it well it's a dumb
it's a democratic figure right it's a
figure that is imbued with the powers we
give it through consent but you don't
and I do think in care majoritarianism I
mean you believe that City I'm a lot
closer to majoritarianism than where we
are now I mean that that's that means
shocking even laundry of the United
States you want to George there's a lot
of fair lighting Jim Crow right what a
fair amount of Rights for to protect
individual rights but it doesn't mean
that a community can't come together and
say we want to tax people to provide
universal health care want to tax people
to provide reparations for something I'm
enough towards I don't mean is it
doesn't mean I think for me what it
means for you I think we are
fundamentally so far from being an
actual democracy in this country go into
the white house is occupied by the
candidate who won four votes the Senate
is occupied by the party in one few
votes because without the Supreme Court
is occupied by the party the one for
your votes in the relevant elections to
offer Supreme Court nominations we are
so far from democracy I would like to
see a pretty big move towards being a
democracy peer majoritarianism in the
sense of like writing a California
Proposition process or not having
individual rights of course not but
majoritarianism way closer to where we
are now not having a filibuster that
kind of thing absolutely and the
question of whether or not isn't
legitimate for the government to do
those kinds of things if the people want
them done a hundred percent so then what
are the limiting principles which are
which are meaning what are the things
that ought to be protected i well again
and then the reason is the reason I ask
this is because you know the Rosato law
argument on behalf of the Rotarian isn't
right but the argument in favor of this
is the are the founding argument you
know for better or for worse the
founding argument I think very much for
better is that there are certain
individual rights that were pre exist
government and the government was
Institute
to protect those individual rights and
that a government that surpasses those
individual rights ceases to act in in as
a as a function of its original mandate
and therefore is illegitimate remain
this is the basics of the of the
Declaration of Independence right and
then the Constitution is designed
specifically with all of these checks
and balances as you discuss in the book
it was designed for gridlock I mean when
people are yell about the gridlock of
American government I always am confused
by that because literally the thing was
designed for gridlock I mean the
founders are not unclear about this in
the federal it's a pretty tremendous
zone of range within where we are now
and what we've agreed is with them is
legitimate to do within our
constitutional structure that you could
do let me ask you something do you think
medicare-for-all would be legitimate
within our constitutional structure I
mean I think that under the fundamental
as interpreted but are you asking me a
descriptive question or a normative
question I'm asking you an or motive
question so the normatively normally a
you believe as you understand a
constitutional structure that you should
be able to do something like
single-payer health care on a federal
level now so I just do and I think
that's a pretty clear point of case all
right and like the way now you're
shifting from descriptive now you're
shifting from normative descriptive so I
asked you already the normative or
descriptive under case law probably you
can do your view as a case law has just
been wrongly decided yes for the last
hundred years on the unsent Wickard V
filburn
right on the on the expansion of the
federal government through the Commerce
Clause to include being able to grow pot
in your own backyard it's ridiculous yes
so I disagree with that but I don't
think we are going to get too deep in
the great founding struggle of America
here like I don't think it is and this
is where I think that we all have our
Great Divide on on your book which is
that you you believe that the divides in
America are chiefly due to reorientation
of of identity no no I don't again I
want to be super clear about this I
think these divides have been much
bigger at other times and they were very
similar divides it's not like people
didn't have the argument you and I are
having right now in nineteen fifty I
mean you had an argument in nineteen
fifty there's much more between
Communists and going all the way to say
like a berry Gold butter the range of
political opinion in 1950 was vast my
point is simply that back then it didn't
split by party and that is very
particular
distinctive implications for a political
system like ours I
to be clear because I think there's
something that people really get wrong
the way in which our political system we
equate polarization with disagreement we
equate it with bitterness or
argumentativeness or incivility none of
that is true the divides have been here
from the beginning I think as you're
actually saying here
they've been bigger out of homes we
don't want more political violence in
this country a hundred years ago then we
have now years ago and fifty years ago
then we have now so I think it is
important for those of us in this moment
who are political pundits and who are
trying to assess us to not play into the
idea that we are living through some
level of fracture and friction that
America's never experienced I think that
there is particularly by the way on the
left a tendency to overstate how bad the
current moment is and how deep the
divides are we have our arguments right
the point of the book is that those
arguments did it used to sort by party
you would have had liberal Republicans
who agreed more or less with me in the
Republican Party you would add
conservative Democrats who were in many
ways more like you in the Democratic
Party you don't have that now and that
is the change the book is tracing III be
interesting if you think this is true I
don't think that even our divides on
equal economic policy to say nothing of
our divides on race and Social Policy
are deeper now than they were 50 years
ago but even if you do I don't think
that is the main thing that has changed
I think those arguments are quite some I
mean we can go back to early issues of
the National Review and see these
debates playing out the difference is
who they're talking to and how those
things establish themselves by party and
then how they're mechanized by party
right because when parties are
internally United they are able to act
with a level of discipline and a level
of competition between them that is
creates one kinda political system
versus when they're internally divided
and they try to handle a disagreements
I've every internal compromise or as was
often the case in American history in
the 20th century through suppression of
those disagreements so when when it
comes to sort of the acceleration of
divides I think that you're right on
some issues and I feel like you're a
little bit off base on on other issues
so I don't know I know so what I feel it
so here's an example so you you do talk
about in sort of the bipartisan approval
of greater government intervention ISM
in the economy in the 1950s and it is
true that the Republican Party reshift
itself in but also a bipartisan
opposition right my partisan opposition
and correct and it's Strom Thurmond was
a very conservative Democratic senator
right 100% and then you see the the
Republican Party reorienting large
you make it sort of a racial story but I
think that that ignores the fact that a
lot of other things went on in the 60s
aside from the civil rights movement I
mean there's a sexual revolution and
there was an economic revolution under
LBJ that really grew government at
extraordinary rates I mean people tend
to pay a lot of attention to the New
Deal and not enough attention to the
Great Society which was an exponential
growth of American government and that
really did result in sort of the Reagan
backlash to that and that was that
that's where the modern party system
really begins is is really in the 60s
you talk a lot about civil rights act as
I say and the Voting Rights Act and all
of that is is appropriate although I
would challenge some of the assertions
of the southern shift which I think
again has been statistically exaggerated
and and a little bit it ignores some of
the underlying economic trends ignores
it ignores the fact that that
Republicans really only took over the
the south in terms of Congress in the
early 1990s now but I've talked about
that producer yeah that's true and and
so I don't there are reasons if it's
right right like in fact it gets to some
interests in upper income Republicans
and younger Republicans were in in the
South we're the ones who were voting
increasing the Republican older Democrat
state Democrats yeah I mean it's a
fascinating thing right identity is so
powerful including partisan identity but
to change you off they need generational
the polite way of saying it's
generational cohort replacement it is
very hard to change people's political
identities and it often doesn't happen
until one generation dies out and those
loyalties begin to fade because the
right generation doesn't have them I
mean there is insight that a lot of
social change is actually generational
for sure but the the reason that I'm
tracing the history a little bit in
terms of the 1960s is that there is a
feeling in the Republican Party and
really inside the kind of conservative
base that you're right and that that was
and that that you were right that there
was agreement about the growth of
government but then there was this
explosion in government that happens in
the 1960s and that extends into the
Republican Party via Nixon and then
there's a backlash to that in the
Republican Party that consolidates
around okay we have now gone too far and
that the continuation of the going too
far has not abated so there's one point
you make in the book where you say you
know Democrats have have constantly sort
of striven for change and Republicans
increasingly are the party of stop no
don't do that well there's two
explanations one is that as you sort of
suggest in the book that the people who
are anti change and who are genetically
and and psychologically predisposed
toward non change have now centralized
in one party the other possibilities
that we've pushed pretty damn far in the
last three decades on a wide variety of
issues and I think their catalytic with
each other
well yes but I think that the
psychological explanation seems to lay
at the feet of psychology a political
change whereas the explanation that I'm
laying forth is is that the Democratic
Party the media that particularly
there's been a real social move toward
the left and that the reaction to that
centralizing the Republican Party is not
chiefly a psychological one as much as
it is a psychological reactions we a
perfectly justifiable I don't think I
don't think I mean I think a argument to
make pretty explicitly in the book by
doing the demographic change chapter is
that all this is being activated and
amplified by genuine real change it's
simply not that people are inventing
that the country is changing
dramatically it is not that people
inventing that things are different
around them I think some of the economic
change is pretty over the last like 30
or 40 years are probably a little less
substantial in this and I think that's
been borne out of the data but it's also
there I mean I don't disagree that the
Great Society and before that the New
Deal changed politics part of the story
about the civil rights act is not that
what happens and I think it's actually
important and often miss point about
American politics what happens though
it's not the Civil Rights Act passes and
then all of a sudden Barry Goldwater
wins the south and tomorrow everybody's
a Republican in the South that doesn't
happen at all you keep a tremendous
amount of southern Democratic senators
southern Democratic members of Congress
you keep a lot of longtime loyalty so it
becomes more competitive in presidential
elections this is a big air of ticket
splitting it's why you get a lot of
cross-party coalition's during this
period it's why Joe Biden is out there
saying hey remember when I used to make
deals with segregation two senators it
that is the moment of politics that he
grew up in I think it's always
interesting how different it was in
living memory but what happens there is
it
what the Dixiecrat blockage did not sort
of how I described it the functionally
and this is a longtime view in political
science function American politics is a
four party system in the 20th century
you had Democrats as we think about them
now Dixiecrats which are a conservative
pretty racist party that entered into a
national power sharing agreement the
Democratic Party as long as they were
allowed to keep going to segregation in
the south liberal Republicans and
conservative Republicans and that it was
the civil rights act and a lot of
changes began happening after that and
happened slowly that allowed for a
realignment the way I think about it is
it partly that racial dimension of
politics and if you look at measures of
party polarization you can't explain it
unless you add this racial dimension in
mid twentieth century America but at
some point that
it doesn't split the parties and in in
to internally the way it once did and
that is what creates a possibility to
have so many people who feel as you're
talking about about economics move over
to the Republican Party that it's that
move where you didn't have this
foundational split inside the parties
that then creates a kind of flywheel
process of polarization and everything
else I mean the process of identity
sorting I talk about where you first
have this move towards ideology where
Democrats become the party of liberals
and Republicans a party of conservatives
and then you have layering on top of
that a move by race I mean you have a
lot more as a percentage
african-american Republicans and you do
today Jackie Robinson is very famously a
Republican if I'm not wrong the earlier
black senators were Republicans and so
that changes Democratic Party becomes
very much a party of a non-white America
right fifty percent of Democrats are
non-white ninety percent of Republicans
are white religion splits much more the
largest religious group of the
Democratic Party now is a religiously
unaffiliated right that's psychological
dimension which i think is really
interesting I have some issues with a
research in this area I think it's
getting it's something important I don't
think it is yet strong enough to base a
huge amount of your political
argumentation I was gonna ask you about
that I don't I think there is something
very real and the openness to change and
conscientiousness like dimensions fixed
and fluid and I talked about it I think
there's some cross-cutting to that - I
think there's cross-cutting I think
he'll call the Aryan personality is not
merely a right-wing figment I think
that's right and so I talk about it as
something that is sorting to be honest
it is something that I think is truer
than we are able to get at but I don't
trust the research enough yet to layer
much on it but nevertheless from what we
know there is a sorting around that
right I talked about the book I actually
think you've talked about this book um
Prius versus pickup by um while are in
Hetherington and they really do show
that over time there's been a very sharp
sorting by this sort of fluid which is
just like high openness to experience
dimension and fix which is this more
conscientiousness dimension different
people cut in different ways but that's
clearly happen and so the way I see it
is more that once the process of
polarization in sorting begun it
happened to a lot of things on top of
each other and created what political
scientists call conflict escalation
instead of disagreeing on one thing now
like things go together much more
cleanly um the Republican Party in 1976
had a national convention platform it
said well there's a disagreement in our
party on abortion some people in our
party think you should be able to get an
abortion
whenever you wanted others think it
should always be illegal and we respect
that disagreement it wasn't until later
the parties polarized on abortion I also
note in the book you look at Bill
Clinton's 96 convention platform he
sounds like Donald Trump on immigration
right the parties are substantially more
different now not because those opinions
and I think this is something we're
circling a bit not because his opinions
that they're fighting over now didn't
exist in American politics but to the
extent they did they existed as
cleavages inside the parties to and when
a cleavages inside the party the party
tries to compromise it or suppress it
when it is between them they try to
escalate it and so what I'm trying to
describe is a difference in political
conflict dynamic not a difference in
political opinions it's sort in the
public the thing political scientists
argue about in my book is it they feel
the mass public is not polarized on
policy very much at all and in fact if
you look at most people they're very
unpolarized on policy I mean Republicans
very heavily support higher taxes on the
rich Democrats have all kinds of views
that would get you canceled on liberal
Twitter like it just doesn't fall the
way political elites fall we are
unusually all of us super ideological
and going way back to converse of
studies in the 50s and 60s only about 15
to 20 percent of the population has a
very clear coherent ideology a sense as
I say of what goes with what
what's changing is just how sort of
those parties are at the top level and
that changes how the mass public reacts
to them at the bottom level because
people are sitting there it's much
easier to make a distinction between two
parties that have very clearly different
views on abortion then two parties are
mixed on them easier to make a
distinction between on immigration if
you care about that a lot between the
party of Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton than the party of George HW Bush
and Bill Clinton and so this party's
change as he's disagreements allocate in
parties as opposed to or between them as
opposed to inside of them it very much
changes the dynamics of American
politics more broadly so I want to get
into that in just one second first
here's the reality if god forbid
somebody in your family should die well
that's gonna be incredibly stressful and
terrible but on top of that it can be
really financially stressful no one ever
wants their family to go through that if
something bad would happen to you the
truth is no one is good at predicting
the future but death is inevitable
that's where policy genius can help at
least take care of your family policy
genius makes finding the right life
insurance a breeze in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price you could save
fifteen hundred bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for
and policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
disability insurance and there are lots
of ways you could plot and could be
something terrible like disease it could
be that you're walking down the street
and piano hits you on the head but if
you don't know what's just around the
corner that's okay
be prepared for anything or at least
make a family prepared with life
insurance in just a few minutes you can
find your best price and apply a policy
genius.com that's policy genius.com
everybody gets the future wrong better
to get your life insurance right go
check them out at policy genius.com to
get back to the sort of identity
politics question because that's really
the area where we disagree I agree with
so much of your analysis on the
polarization of the parties and it's
obviously true that all of the
ideological diversity within the parties
is basically gone at this point maybe
the Blue Dog Democrat is basically gone
the very liberal Republican is
effectively being moved out I mean you
can see people who are not even liberal
Republicans if they if they cross the
party are now being sort of sent into
the wilderness
I wished into the cornfield so you know
that that out on the ice floe there are
exactly that sort of stuff is obviously
happening I guess the question is when
it comes to how to have political
conversations and how to cure the
polarization a lot of that to me is
going to rely on having conversations
like the one we're having where neither
of us feel that our quote unquote
identity is threatened as opposed to
most of the conversations that are being
activated this is true right and left
people who are activating conversations
solely on the basis of identity then
this goes back to the question I was
asking before and that I think we sort
of escaped it I want to come back around
to and that is do you think that there
are gradations of danger in the kinds of
identities that are appealed to in
politics yes I don't think there is any
doubt that certain kinda certain kinds
of identities are more fundamental and
they are harder for people to cross and
when they are threatened people react
more strongly and I think that in
general the two that have dominated in
American politics or maybe the three are
racial religious and then party and I do
think party's a bigger kind of identity
than we often give a credit for and
should be understood as an identity I
mean again this way I push you a little
bit of leftist ear saying I agree it's
funny that's why I want the mug it's why
I'm not leaving it and I also thought
about I think was the least dangerous
concept but I do think that when these
things all begin to layer on top of each
other and that's the story I'm telling
in the book one of the points I'm making
is that we have to understand political
identities as identities and that's why
I go through a lot of this other
separate from it because I want to be
clear for this for the audience we were
talking a couple minutes ago about
political psychology Reese
about psychological substrates of
people's politics later in life here I'm
talking about research about how people
form identities which i think is much
much stronger and we can go through the
Henry Collegeville stuff if you'd like
but I think that what is happening now
is we have to understand that a lot of
the polarization in the country is
actually coming from political identity
which is fed into bi-racial by religious
by Geographic is another I think quite
big one kinds of identity so I'll give
you an example this michael paths are
the political scientist at UC irvine he
shows an impala if you looked at
racialized controversies which we had
plenty of in the 90s they were very
divisive in the country but they didn't
split by parties so if you polled the OJ
Simpson verdict or the Bernard Goetz
trial in New York people had different
views but those different views were not
different by Republicans and Democrats
if you poll racialized controversies now
george zimmerman or a couple years ago
whether or not one is my favorite
whatever not 12 years of slave should
win an oscar but is not something the
parties took position on but if i'm
remembering the numbers here correctly
69% of democrats said yes 12 eases slave
should win an oscar 12 percent of
Republicans said yes so what you have is
a layering of these identities on top of
each other and then they come out in
these political identities which in many
ways are much more comfortable arguing
about right right uh III just the four
just to finish one more study here I
shown the book a study that I think is
pretty disturbing which is by Shantou
younger and Sean Westwood where they
show that if you give people a form and
you ask them to rate somebody applying
for a scholarship you now see very very
high rates of discrimination simply
based on whether or not the hypothetical
scholarship applicant was a Republican
or Democrat in high school these
political identities are standing in for
a lot they are very powerful on how we
treat each other and they're at the core
of a lot of political polarization and I
think much more so the Corbett than some
of these other identities are talking
about so I think the opposite it feels
to me like the policies have been
layered onto the political identities by
politically motivated actors what I mean
by that yes right and and so and so the
the and so what I'm suggesting is that
the layering is the problem not the
identity group identification which as
you identify has been part of American
politics forever but people identifying
by party people identifying by value
group even to a certain point a
politically by religious group is not a
problem politically by religious group
it starts to become more of a problem
right if you identify we really have
always done that right yes
but the but doing it by racial group has
always been
biggest problem in American history and
doing it by racial group today and
layering politics on top of racial group
makes it almost impossible to have a
conversation in the sense that if you
believe that you're an immutable
characteristic about yourself is
threatened by somebody else's political
position then there is no possible way
to have a rational conversation and this
is how you end up with the idea that you
appearing on my show you're gonna get
unbelievable blowback because I am a
threat to people who are transgender or
I'm a threat to people who are black or
I'm a threat to people who are Hispanic
now I have never said a word about black
identity as being bad because black
identity is not bad meaning like if you
are a black person that is not bad
there's nothing wrong with you then and
not only that I have forcibly gone after
and taken more abuse for it anybody
going after the alt right and and racism
coming from that from that particular
purview you're gonna get hit for being
on the show specifically because the
idea is that because I believe that that
Trayvon Martin was acquitted by the
George Zimmerman was acquitted and at
the DOJ could not come up with evidence
that George Zimmerman was racially
motivated in the killing of Trayvon
Martin that therefore you are speaking
with an overt racist because I took a
position on that trial that obviously
threatens identity so one I think
sometimes people over rate the bravery
it takes to appear on show like I will
live through my cancellation like I
would not be here if I thought it was
gonna like destroy my career forever so
I think sometimes the amount of bravery
people suggested takes pundits to wander
around have conversations in the current
era is amplified by a kind of desire to
make things all seem a little bit more
dangerous and polarized and make the
other side see more unreasonable than
they are I have plenty of conversations
on my show with people I disagree with
like Roger and Andrew Sullivan and so on
and my show doesn't get cancelled it's
all it's all fine people live um you get
a lot of blowback I think somebody's
deserve it frankly but I was looking at
a speech you gave a couple years ago and
I don't know what it was actually titled
but of course on YouTube it's titled
sister friendship hero destroys the
concept of white privilege I think that
when you do these speeches the way that
speech was constructed is full of a lot
of jabs you talk about like the people
you disagree with sounding like you're
22 month old spitting up um you don't
try to lower the amount of threat people
feel from you but I actually don't
really want to talk about you in this i
guy what I want to make is a
a point about race and politics which is
it is true that being say African and
American in this country races up
politics has often been a threat to you
like a deep real threat to your ability
of course that's a decent life and that
is true for people of different
sexualities and it's your firm a lot of
us in different ways and so one of the
things that I do think I profoundly
disagree on with you is it may be that
bringing that into politics the reason
is often combustible is that that is a
place where there's been some of our
deepest injustice not our only injustice
no I agree pastand the an in particular
I think it's combustible because people
have a sense deep in deep inside that if
we were to really account for
historically what we've done the amount
of sis filed the amount of societal
disruption that would take reparations
and other things it would be so much
that people don't even want to face it
it's like much easier to suppress it
which again by the way is what we did
for much of 20th century politics so
these things are I'm not coming here
with an agenda to solve politics much as
an agenda to solve racial divisions in
politics but the idea that racial
divisions are part of politics you're
going to somehow like lock them out it
just seems wild to me I mean of course
one of the many things we have to deal
with in politics is racial division
politics is a place where we're able to
take our divisions and hopefully deal
with them non-violently so they don't
explode in other parts of our country in
other parts of our society now I have
very deep concerns we've become unable
to deal with anything in politics
because racial divisions be it
healthcare be anything but that's a set
of arguments I'll make about the way our
political system now functions not so
much about whether or not is viable to
bring these disagreements into the
political sphere but I think that at
root there is also a fundamental
disagreement here on how many of these
political disagreements go to identity
and that may be the biggest disagreement
of all which is that I agree there are
obviously certain points where there are
policies that are threatening to black
people and we're designed to be
threatening to black people all right I
mean most of American history was
replete with exactly such policies the
invocation of policies that are not only
facially neutral but not designed to be
discriminatory toward lack people the
activation of the racial trigger when it
comes to the invocation of group
identity in response to that I think is
incredibly dangerous and it ought to be
used with great care and I feel like you
downplay the amount of care that ought
to be used for that because you're
pretty sanguine about the idea that
policy is generally racialized I don't
think I do downplay the amount of care
you need I think I take a lot of care
with it
and I think actually one of my criticism
of you is I think you don't I think that
you say a lot of very inflammatory
things that offend people and then when
they're offended you weaponize on
defense back at them and I think it's a
careless way to treat people on this and
I think the whole idea that you
shouldn't bring race into politics is a
careless way to treat our racial history
yes it needs to be careful like yes you
need to be cautious yes you need to try
to hear the best of all sides and to and
something I do in the book which like
among other things has given me a little
bit of blowback is I try to have a
reasonably sympathetic account though
it's not my account it's not my position
of the feelings of white fear in the
country right now like I try to have a
pretty sympathetic account of what it
feels like to live in a country where
you thought you understood what the
power order was and it is changing and I
talked about that loss of social status
as being something that you have to take
seriously in American politics sort of
no matter what you actually believe
about American politics because if you
don't it's a very dangerous thing um so
it's actually not my view that you
treated me you should deal with it
without much care it's my view that you
just do still have to deal with it we
don't get to dodge our hard issues
because they could be combustible it
just requires us to deal with them in
more decent faith so I mean obviously I
think we ought to deal with hard issues
and I want to get to that in just one
second but first let's talk about saving
time and money you know it's not really
a great use of your time or your money
to take a bunch of packages schlep them
to the post office in the back of your
car and then wait in line at the post
office post office is great but why not
just do everything online stamps calm is
completely online plus you save five
cents off every first class stamp and up
to 40% off shipping rights simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it once your mail is ready just
hand it to your mail carrier or drop it
in the mailbox it is indeed that simple
think about how much time and money you
could have saved on letters and packages
over the years with stamps com you get
discounted postage rates that you can't
even get at the post office there's no
equipment to lease no long term
commitments if you even consider using
one of those expensive postage meters
while you're living in the past bad
decision instead check out stamps
comments and no-brainer it saves you
time it saves you money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm you
really should take advantage of services
that help you like this I do I use
stamps calm personally we use it here
daily we're - right now my listeners get
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage as a
digital scale no long term commitment
just go to Sam's comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in Shapiro that's
Tam's commenter shapiro it's sort of
fascinating the example that you just
gave and it is an example that i came
across in the book you know obviously
where you're talking about sort of the
the fear by white people of the
burgeoning demographic minority but
burgeoning demographic majority you post
it just now as sort of a a an attempt to
understand the mind of people who feel
that fear and as a conservative right
i've always felt and when i read the
book i got this feeling to that you're
sort of speaking conservatism in the
second language when you're trying to
provide a explained explanation of how
people are feeling that what you're
actually doing is racializing a fear
that most people don't feel racially
they fear they feel culturally and look
well and i talked a lot about ashley
giardina's research here which is that
there is a tendency part of the in
periods of demographic change and thread
to see and i think this is a distinction
is not often made well on the left but I
do say quite explicitly in the book that
you can have one of the things that is
happening right now is we're seeing and
you can see it's very clearly in Survey
data an increase in white identity um
when you ask white people just like how
do you feel about being white you see a
change there and you see a change in in
the direction of feeling more connected
to whiteness in feeling that to be an
identity that people possibly need to
defend um that can happen with or
without an increase in out-group
hostility um and so I talked a fair
amount actually about the the fact that
for most people who are seeing an
increase in white identity you actually
don't see it according alongside an
increase in out-group hostility now for
some you see it with a very sharp rise
in out-group hostility but one of the
things that I actually think is an
interesting question our politics is
Donald Trump MIT and I know we have been
talking to him about much here but
Donald Trump mixes of these things in
ways I think are probably quite
politically suboptimal for him the kind
of politician who worries me more is
somebody who'd be very good at catering
to white identity without offering as
much out-group hostility because that
kind of aggro possibilities actually
quite unpopular but the question of
defending privilege I mean actually talk
in the book about a study that shows it
if you go and you remind white college
students and talk to them about white
privilege
they were then gonna score like if you
test him after or higher in various
racial resentment in fact it's like you
have to be very careful in the way you
talk about this particular in a country
with a lot of change I don't think I'm
racializing things that aren't
racialized but I am trying to deal with
the fact that
have a series of interlocking
demographic changes are happening all at
once on top of by the way a lot of
technological changes and political and
social changes that are creating a sense
of just change it is happening too fast
I mean I quoted some length by William
bars different speeches about how the
secular left is pursuing an organized
destruction of religion it's very much
not my view that you're just seeing one
kind of threat under operation here and
in fact I think people actually way
underestimate the power of the religious
threat going on right now I imagine
about that Rod Dreher on my show why
I've had Robert Jones on my show and
been trying to explore that as well I
think these things are very important
but I think people underestimate the
degree to which they are and I know you
won't let me using the word
intersectional well no I mean listen
leave the original
the the thing that I've seen know a lot
of folks on the left doing gen cast and
I've talked about this little yeah you
know is is going back to you know sort
of the original definition of
intersectionality which of course is
perfectly valid you know the idea that
you have intersectional identity in in
sense you could be a woman and you can
be discriminate against an black person
and discriminate against a black woman
is discriminated against in a different
way that that's perfectly valid but the
idea that the that you can sort of set
up a hierarchy of victimization
inherently at the hands of white
majoritarian society is inevitably going
to set up the white population in
opposition to that you have now declared
that there is a that you are inherently
part of this white hierarchy of power
that is cramming down on everybody else
and of course that's going to create a
reactionary backwash that that is going
to just be the natural result of being
excluded from the from the coalition of
the supposedly dispossessed I mean
that's that's one of the things that
that I think is happening and I think
that's less racialized than it is a
reaction to the racialization and so
these the chicken and the egg here is
very difficult well but the question is
how to stop that but I don't get the
sense that you necessarily want to stop
that I don't think you're going to be
able to stop it right now anything that
I will say yeah I do you think it's I
mean you don't choose these colors for
your book that's all about to get better
right of that dumb what I will say is
just finish the thought what I will say
on this is that what I'm trying to do in
the book this is and you've read it yeah
it's not a pollen it's not a plum ik
like it's not me explaining to you how I
think the world should be I have a
little bit of solution stuff in the back
chapter and I'm sure you disagree with
some of it but in general like you can
pretty much rely
I wrote that chapter as like a hostage
letter like I don't want to write a
solutions Chapter III down solutions are
all yeah anything like get rid of the
filibuster yeah that kind of thing um I
am trying to describe how system is
working like this is a book of to go
back to Vox explanatory journalism it is
not a book of like here is what Ezra
Klein thinks is right about the world
whether I treat I speak conservatism as
a second language or not like I'm less
interested in sort of who's right in
this at the moment than I am in trying
to give people stronger and better micro
foundations for understanding how
politics works but I want people to do
is understand why political actors
ranging from you and me to Mitch
McConnell to Donald Trump - you know
staffers etc make the decisions they do
I think I have for somebody who's
clearly on the liberal side of that
debate a pretty sympathetic account of
what Mitch McConnell did during the
Merrick garland affair trying to explain
like how that was a very straightforward
application of his own incentives and
the rules of American politics and
asking him to take one of the most
ideological consequential votes he'll
probably ever have as a Senate Majority
Leader and not see it as an ideological
vote in a time of high ideological
polarization which does at some point
that theory is gonna fail right and so
I'm trying to change the way people see
politics is working because I think
we're baselined to a way it worked in
the twentieth century that is no longer
how it works given the party structure
we have look there we can talk about
depolarization my I would like to have
had and I will tell you that I worked at
this um it's funny that some of the most
i sometimes wish you gave your null
hypotheses more clearly in the book um I
spent a lot of time looking at
literature on depolarization I don't
think anything works at scale I think
that there's definitely evidence that
you can do things like intergroup
contact and if you moderate and
structure things so people are working
towards a common goal and so forth it
will depolarize it just is very hard to
figure out how you do that at scale
given all the forces of moving towards
polarization given all the media outlets
and move towards polarization give it
out different the parties are from each
other I mean if we have and I don't know
who's gonna win the Democratic primary
at this point but if we have a Bernie
Sanders versus Donald Trump election in
2020 just the size of that difference is
really dramatic and that's the kind of
size of difference whether or not we
have of this year not that we're moving
towards I will know that and it did it
did feel since Bernie Sanders gonna win
the primaries they the line that you
have very late in the book where you
suggest that the best evidence that the
Republican Party has sort of moved off
institutional moorings is the 2016 race
in which Trump won the nomination but
Hillary won the nomination in 2016 and
now we're looking at and I mean I social
I've said yeah I have combination I
don't think there's any doubt that the
Democratic Party is polarizing moving
left I mean there are some differences
in the Democratic Party what it can do
and how it can move left and I talked
about that in the book because of the
way their coalition is structured and
they have to win center-right voters
because of the geography of the
electoral college I mean there's a
discussion on the left about how to win
sort of downscale more conservative
White's in Wisconsin that there's not a
matching discussion on the right about
how to win you know like
african-american voters in Los Angeles
but nevertheless like I don't think
there's any doubt that I'm erotic party
is moving in a polarized direction and I
think one of the big unanswered
questions of the book for me is are the
differences between the Democratic and
Republican parties is it ever kind of
party following the Republican Party on
a lag
I don't think Bernie Sanders and Trump
or equivalent politicians on a lot of
different levels including by the way
that whatever they say about him Bernie
Sanders is a very longtime American
politician he's not an outsider for us
he was a runner up in 2016 in the
Democratic primary but nevertheless like
you cannot look at the Democratic Party
and not see that it is moving and so
that like is the story of the book that
year by year the parties are moving I
mean some data I show in there is it
Bill Clinton was in his time the most
polarizing president we had since the
advent of polling right then it was
Barack Obama then it was Donald Trump
right so every president has gotten
higher in this and those are presidents
of different parties with dramatically
different personal rhetorical political
styles so what is happening here is
structural I really am trying to move a
lot of the analysis off of individual
like in political journalism we
personalize things that are actually
systems this is a trying to now to
analyze American politics as a system
and see how it's changed over the past
that's called 50 80 years so in the
chief critique that I had of the book
and as again I recommend everybody read
it there's so much good information and
really is fascinating why we're polarize
go get it at your bookstore but the the
chief critique that I had of the books I
feel like because of the way that you
define the problem and then because of
the way that you defend identity
politics broadly as we are all engaged
in identity politics you have now
foreclosed a solution and everything in
the last chapter as you rightly I mean
you basically say it straight out it's a
band-aid on a gaping wound right like
that's nothing getting rid of the
filibuster ain't gonna cure these
problems on a systemic level what I mean
by that is you said you set out a system
whereby our increase
identity are an increasing sense of
identity invested in politics and
separating us
but you've laid out at the very
beginning a defense of identity politics
broadly speaking not identify would
really I do want to push this because
whether I defend it or not defend it I
just view it as a force I I'm not
defending the like the existence of US
politics I'm saying that it's here and
we need to understand it that's my view
on the identity - I mean something we
haven't talked too much about it's like
the the foundations of identity and that
one of the foundations of identity and
particularly the way it becomes
combustible in politics which is I think
primarily where you're focused here is
when you just get into in group out
group dynamics one of things I've shown
in the book using Henry College shells
research and others is it is incredibly
easy to get there I mean you can do it
based on almost anything and sports is a
great example of something where the
stakes are not objectively that high I'm
not myself a sports fan but the identity
is very dramatic I mean people really
care if their team wins or loses we have
riots in the aftermath I mean the whole
thing and that's a little bit why when I
come here I think it's interesting to me
that you you're so down on it any
politics but you're doing strong
in-group out-group stuff I mean like
facts don't care about your feelings is
like a hole I'd actually love to talk
about that if we um is a whole different
situation around like what you're saying
is that people on the other side of you
like they're not factual you don't
really have to listen to them their
feelings oriented snowflakes they're
crying into their liberal or leftist
ears mug and that's a way of telling the
audience like that is just identity and
ingre back group stuff it's very classic
like in some ways I like I see the
incentive there but I find it just weird
to see somebody doing that and arguing
against of any politics like that is
identity politics that's how it works
again because I differentiate it between
the types of identity politician that
doesn't fit the social science of how
identity actually functions in people's
heads and the other thing that I think
is I mean nobody can become not black
who is black people obviously become not
leftist or leftist they're people who
become leftist who are not leftist
there's a malleability there's a
malleability thing is such an important
distinction as you do and the other are
we doing in politics dude I mean if we
can if we if there's no malleability in
our ability to change other people's
opinions not only is the book pointless
but all the politics is well know
because I don't think identity is
determinative in the way you do I think
that people from the same identity will
have different politics and identity is
something that shapes people's politics
I actually have a line in there because
I think one thing you will sometimes
read and people have said this in box is
that all politics is identity politics
and I'm pretty
careful not to say that and the reason I
don't say it is that I don't want people
to think that identity is like it's like
classical physics driving politics it if
you can simply like match people's
identities on the list you know exactly
what they're gonna think or do that's
clearly not true I mean just like look
around and not only that but people have
a lot of identity simultaneously so
Melissa Deniz they're contradictory they
come out at different times and only to
understand a lot of Elections is their
fights over what identity we should be
inhabiting what identity should be
activated when but one reason I think
this is important I do have a whole
chapter about the way we absorb
information and particularly things like
identity protective cognition and one of
the ways in which I think identity is
particularly dangerous in politics is
once we've locked into an identity that
we feels threatened it becomes very hard
for us to listen it becomes very
difficult to listen and so when you
begin doing things with which the with
what they actually say to people is you
don't have to listen to the other side
or if you do if outside wins you are
going to lose it becomes very hard for
us to hear it becomes very hard for us
to actually change the opinion to your
point about malleability I don't think
the problem of malleability is identity
I think the problem of malleability is
out-group in a sense of personal stakes
right if people under lists are deeply
related up there's somewhat related but
they're not purely related like if there
are different ways to set up a
conversation and if people feel in the
conversation that depending on who wins
that really affects them or they feel
that everybody's in the circle together
um those are really different like
something that is just if a thing I find
fascinating about you is that like you
operate in very different ways in very
different contexts like something you've
done really well in this conversation I
see it because I do it too or try to in
conversations like this is you've drawn
the circle kind of around us right you
said we're both hearing it together
you're a liberal I don't hate liberals I
only hate leftist because they hate me
like you're fact-based like I think the
book is good but there's a lot of work
on this sort of like macro daily wire
world to cut this divide and say to
people in a way that deeply offends them
like you're dumb your feelings already
dig your snowflake you should stop
crying and that stuff makes it hard to
hear and so when I think about what
you're gonna do in politics I think
about a lot of like how did you see
de-escalate conversations not how do you
tell people not to bring identities they
have to have or that they're very deeply
rooted to psychologically or otherwise
into politics of course you're gonna
bring that into it like they're bringing
everything else in their lives their
resources the actual economic position
they're in like how once they're there
be able to have conversations I am
pessimistic about it right that's part
of what the book is saying that I think
the way the incentives are the media and
other things are structured it becomes
much harder to do that but I don't I
really disagree with the cut where it's
like some identities are fine others are
not but like we can just like all be at
war with each other and as long as we
are not like out war over things that
relate to you know like immutable
characteristics in the way you see them
like it'll be fine I mean these things
all operate in politics somewhat
similarly and in other countries and
other cultures and even here at other
times they've become very dangerous in
different ways I mean my god like look
at like Ireland during the Troubles but
when you leave my mutable
characteristics to how things get very
dangerous we need is proms you can't
actually resolve through a political
system I mean that's true but as you
strengthen the identities and again I
think political identities are the
softest form of identity the when you
strengthen other we have evidence that
people discriminate like very
dramatically on political identity now
they're not soft to people who hold them
but listen I mean you're not only saying
the leftist want to destroy your life
like take away your well I mean
literally there are groups that are
dedicated to no I understand but that's
what I mean I think oh I didn't identify
advertiser so this is no no I'm not
telling you that people aren't out to
get you like I saw that video of you and
your family getting like hounded by
right-wing or like you like like they
all right yeah that was I thought a
horrifying thing I mean this stuff is
fair but I mean the political identity
is very power right but the point that
I'm making is that or that I was going
to make is that once you strengthen the
idea of of identities that are more
deeply rooted than politics because
politics is is a slightly later human
invention than tribe or race I mean
these are things that that are a little
bit more biologically fundraise I mean
right right so somebody's very shifty or
American are not American over a human
history right in a tribe of tribal would
be a better description right try a
tribal or familial ruler ethnicity right
however you however you derive that they
might Lydian versus yours correct that
stuff is really really good in the
substrates of the brain whereas politics
can be mapped onto that but it has to be
mapped on to that and so you're opposing
the mapping and I'm suggesting that and
I'm not opposed to you're not opposing
and and so the the to combine that with
the idea that a pure majoritarian big
government can solve the problem scares
the living hell out of me because at the
same time
polarizing you're making the case that
we should have basically a more
majoritarian system more powerfully able
to cram down on an increasingly
polarized country by group identity well
when you put it like that it doesn't
sound great let me put it my way super
sure which is what I would say is one of
the frustrating things about politics in
this era for people is that
disagreements are very hard to resolve
in any way that they can see change and
progress or even change and harm to
their actual interests we're constantly
because almost nothing passes ever we
are constantly locked in the conflict
part of a disagreement and so you don't
get like the Liberals passing
single-payer health care and then people
didn't say oh did I like that or did I
hate that and so do I want to bring them
back to power or do I not or similarly
Republicans run on repealing Obamacare
for a decade they get the white house
they get the house they get the Senate
and they don't repeal Obamacare well the
main deeply conflicting promises
throughout but yes well yeah they
definitely they definitely really
promise to get rid of public the point I
want and their promising to repeal
Obamacare but also not affect
pre-existing conditions you can't do all
these things at once I agree with and
and and we should I would love don't
know fall time but I'd love to talk
about health care with you I'm sure we
might have finished all my liberal tears
by that but I think it is a healthier
form of politics for political parties
to have to appeal to a majority of the
public not go to some like unbelievably
majoritarian system but just like in
general to govern you need 51% of the
vote like that's how most parliamentary
systems work and if you get that which I
think is an important distinction here
if you get that you can actually govern
like in other countries if you win power
in Canada or you in power in the UK what
it means is you have a governing
coalition if that is like the actual
thing that that means if you win the
presidential election here like we might
have in 2021 president Bernie Sanders
and Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
right and that's gonna be a very
frustrating outcome for everyone and so
one thing that I argue is the
polarization is particularly difficult
when it does not allow you to govern
because then are we just caught in a
constant fight for power but not an
ability to have an accountability
feedback loop with the public where okay
these folks came in they got voted in
either I voted for them or I didn't it
but they're in now like do I like what
happened or not instead we're in endless
arguments about why things didn't happen
Donald Trump says of Democrats are
obstructing him and impeaching him and
keeping him from doing anything and
Barack Obama says that the Republicans
are obstructing him coming after him
keeping him from doing all the things he
wanted to do right and both of them to
some degree are right right wherever you
come down on who's morally right to do
it is never less the case that neither
Donald Trump nor Barack Obama got like
25 percent of their agenda through and
the way that they imagined it over the
course of their presidencies and I think
that is a problem I think that is
something that makes it very hard to see
disagreements coming in to anything that
could shake people out of where they are
I am look if I could imagine a great way
to take down polarization to take out
the group is to impulse in the human
psyche I'd be open to it I'm definitely
interested in doing that I just don't
believe in it like that is like in my
sort of like facts don't care about your
feelings like like I don't think that
research cares that I don't like it so
like that's where I come down like I'm
pessimistic on this but I do think you
can have political systems that work
better or worse inside conditions of
polarization and I think would be better
to have a political system where people
could govern and the public could decide
if they liked the way the governance had
happened as opposed to a political
system where nobody can govern and the
public then has to decide like why did
nothing happen
why are my problems not getting resolved
why do I feel like I keep trying to make
American politics better and it only
keeps getting worse and that kind of in
addition to all the other forms of
polarization we have not just building
frustration I think is very dangerous so
again I I would agree with you if I
actually agree with the premise of what
government is designed to do but then
that gets back to sort of the founding
debate about what government is designed
to do in the first place and you're
assuming that a government is designed
to achieve the needs of the majority or
achieve the needs of people who let's
say supermajority who broadly agree that
they want to do in a thing
whereas I believe the government is
designed to protect fundamental rights
and basically nothing else so that is it
that is a stark difference between
liberal and conservative yes I mean
leftist that is a that is an old and
real difference but I would say that I
think for most of the public that is not
the difference in American politics it's
a pretty you got a it's a pretty small
hobbyist contingent who ends up having
the very deep argument between like a
true royalty and liberalism and a true
libertarianism I enjoy doing it like we
can have a beer and do that we can hang
out here and do it I like it
and like we should like have some fun I
enjoyed having George Will on my podcast
he came on and made that argument for a
while and like we go back and forth I
think the Republican and sort of
right-wing turn against democracy itself
which has gotten stronger as democracies
become more of a threat
right-wing interests I think that's
dangerous and like that's it it is a
good debate to have that gets to very
fundamental differences in American
politics most people like if you poll
them they want the problem solved that
is what they want government to do so in
terms of like my view on this of what is
making politician ways the planner just
to hold on curve for a moment here the
way the mass public is it having a
building frustration because nothing
changes that to me when you talk about
what makes politics dangerous like that
is what makes politics dangerous when
you can't resolve conflict that is where
things become whose that is where things
become violence in the streets the
Merrick garland thing I make the
argument that Mitch McConnell did what
you would expect me to do given his
incentives you can also very much
imagine a future where the Supreme Court
becomes unusable or the Supreme Court
has three open seats for a period of ten
years because nobody can come to
agreement and in an extended period of
divided government and that kind of
thing when we lose a capacity to resolve
disagreement or make the system function
I think that is what begins to shake up
the foundations of systems because most
people they don't want to watch or
listen to our podcasts or our youtubes
but they just want is for their lives to
work and like if politics isn't doing
that for them they're gonna get pissed
yeah my problem is I don't think no
matter how you slice politics it's going
to make your life work I think you're
gonna make your life work in the best
you can hope you can have them in to
leave you the hell alone but with all of
that said I want to ask you one more
question
because we've gone way over time because
this is so enjoyable it really is and
thank you so much for being on the
program I do have a couple more
questions I want to ask you if you want
to hear Ezra's answers on free speech
and about the big debate between Carlos
masa and steven crowder Voxx took the
position that steven should actually get
kicked off of youtube if you want to
hear Ezra's answers on that become a
daily wire member go to daily where com
click subscribe you can hear the rest of
our conversation over there well as a
recline it really has been a pleasure to
have you here I'm sorry that we don't
have more time honestly we've gone
probably 25 minutes over here we could
easily go for four hours pick up his
book why were polarize definitely worth
the read and be sure to listen to the
Ezra Klein show and as I say again title
the book is why repose desert thanks so
much for having me
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike Joyner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer case Winterton
our guests are booked by Caitlyn Manor
the post-production is supervised by
Alex's Singaram editing is by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Nico Geneva title graphics
are by Cynthia Angulo the Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020s
Mike daily wire
[Music]